just gonna make a one-off video for
YouTube or Mike or this might be
stripped for audio we're just gonna
freestyle here you know Weezy inspired
sitting here in a hotel lobby about to
do my shoe polish drop the case was
collaboration I did with shoe palace a
retailer just super grateful as we wrap
up the year it's a it's December 11th
twelve eleven just thinking a lot about
twenty nineteen feeling very fresh
thinking a lot about you know a lot
about a lot of different things
Facebook's on my mind very fascinated
and excited about exploiting it next
year I think the world is running away
from it which makes me feel passionate
to run into it thinking about my team a
lot a commitment to making more content
very excited about the team garyvee
handle for 2019 a lot of good young
talent big shout out to max I feel like
a lot of like our vibes forget I think
we're getting tighter continuation of
written content Twitter like if we're if
we're doing a little bit of a 20-19
predictions I'm gonna dominate 50 to 80
year olds on Facebook I'm gonna put out
a hundred tweets a day on my Twitter
account which would mean that I'm gonna
give up a little bit of the control not
every tweet is gonna be me but I want to
indicate that d-roc was the one who
tweeted it we're just sitting on so much
content I just want to get a lot of
stuff out I think next year is gonna be
the decline of the organic reach of
Instagram I think they're gonna be
crying about the numbers not being as
good so that's running through my mind
because everybody's become
one-dimensional in that platform a lot
of selling for me next year and not like
selling like I mean more like empathy
wines is gonna have to pop we haven't
started the marketing we announced it
but I'm excited about that
[Applause]
very I got at least one more sneaker in
me next year likely to feel like there
might be one or two new little things
that I want to work on accessories
apparel different [ __ ] like that so I'm
excited about selling but in the form of
branding continuing to disproportionally
be
singular entrepreneur that's bringing
the most value for free to every other
entrepreneur and then creating products
that have nothing to do with my
information that people are consuming
and if they are curious to want to
purchase those things because they drink
wine or wear sneakers then that is
phenomenal but never giving with
expectation the great downfall of what I
observed in 2018 is how many people
think they're tricking their audience
and putting out [ __ ] and then creating a
VIP rope or a closed group or cutting
off the video halfway through and if you
want it pay for it the the inability for
the market to understand that just build
a brand and everything good will come of
it 1:37 p.m. big year in 2019 the men's
publishing company that I own I'm
excited about that the global expansion
of vaynermedia Singapore South America
Canada all in play Singapore xaloc Manor
speakers forming the best speaking
Bureau in the world Vayner Sports AJ is
now certified gonna be fun to watch my
brother become the best football agent
in the world over the next half decade
continuing to go into eSports and
hip-hop and things that I naturally just
like investing you'll be seeing more
content for me about taking investing
meetings by the time you watch this I'm
not sure if we're gonna put out our
first piece but I set guerrilla pitch we
filmed it so we had a great two years of
my meetings that I used to take with
hip-hop artists that was content well
the investment pictures I take again
creating a media platform the people
that pitched me you know they're either
gonna get my money or your money or
exposure to VC's have I've
I've got a knack and ability and a
growing capability of putting people on
without asking for anything in return
whether that's a hip-hop star or now a
start-up that's exciting to me I'm
excited to see some my predictions play
out next year I think I think you'll see
some of the things I've been talked
about play out so that's good it's
always good
penetrating basketball culture a lot of
NBA superstars [ __ ] with me on
instagram DMing with them I'm excited
for NBA all-star weekend Charlotte
Super Bowl party the Vayner Sports one
thirty seven pm Super Bowl party is
gonna be real in Atlanta bartering I'm
all about that barter life you know
trying to sell hundreds of cases of
empathy in one shot what can I do for
you same for the athletes we sign in
Vayner Sports that'll be fun
training talent like this team Gary Vee
I would rip my arm off to be on Team
Gary B as a creator or a general manager
just we've got it down now it's like
designer writer gift maker
creator video pictures animated gifs
animator or general managers the sins
the cow you know the kind of like Rishi
like if you're not a creator max like
we'll try to make you a GM that's good
these are the things I'm thinking about
for my business life next year
what's that sports cards absolutely
sports cards is something I'm going to
lean anymore I'm sure trash talk is
gonna be huge next year slipping it's
all this thing you know what's so funny
Dirac there is only one thing we do how
can I have the greatest legacy as an
entrepreneur ever is what I'm thinking
about it will take me creating
businesses like I need a empathy to sell
for a half a billion dollars to one of
the biggest wine companies I'm gonna
need vaynermedia to be a billion
fëanor X to be a billion dollar revenue
organization I'm gonna need Vayner
sports to be a top-five firm I'm gonna
need that but there isn't an
entrepreneur within [ __ ] striking
distance of the obsession of bringing
the most value to his art for her
audience and I'm doing it at all for
trash talk is a free education for the
people that have 137 dollars in their
bank this you know dailyvee the white
papers that all that the deck that I
made that's for the people you know make
you know the the unbelievable commitment
I'm making in 22192 service small
businesses entrepreneurs and startups in
the form of a disproportionately big
announcement in January
I'm hungry as [ __ ] to be a generational
entrepreneur and I'm well on my way and
I haven't even [ __ ] stepped onto the
field for the national anthem of what
I'm up to
so you can imagine so I'm not in the
first quarter I'm not at halftime I'm
still putting on my cleats in the
[ __ ] dugout I we haven't even sung
the [ __ ] national anthem people
confused I tell kids to be patient I'm
43 and I'm patient as [ __ ] the [ __ ] do
you think I think you're up to at 29
it's gonna be a great year
you